welcome to this video playing H
sacrifices he starts with one but I
don't take it you have the smooth Maura
I'm aware of the like to decline it and
people who play that gambit quite often
don't feel as home in this Roxy buying
structures so even though I'm not a huge
fan of this particular structure for
black I still feel that it's a decent
practical choice against the typical
gambit here and let's see what happens
night to d5 yeah that's very common in
the maroc see cannot stick it night
before as an interesting move maybe well
I'm not even attacking there is a for
interesting maybe a 4b for Bishop g5 be
take c 5 i'm not sure about this maybe
let's try in general I wouldn't mind to
open up the eval
I really wasn't sure about this pawn
takes Knight before is just bad for
white I mean just a pawn for nothing so
we asked to take on c5 not quite sure
what are you thinking about yeah so yep
I have to go back yeah I guess he will
take on d6 and the question is that is
white better here on am I about equal
how to save and ce4 his week with these
six also is and we have politics i guess
my dear father is a good move i guess
here either for putting it on d5 or
taking only six depending on the
circumstances well definitely
okay maybe this was possible but should
be too so it didn't take which is
probably right only six I mean 25 is
probably the better but a way to play
should be six not sure it doesn't really
do that much looks it to where i can
take d5 and then he has to check with a
pawn because of night before i mean i
don't really believe in enough
compensation down but he has a couple of
interesting options you can even try to
sacrifice the rook there on c1 I mean
ineffective exchange yeah like this so
I'm grabbing this here and this of
course i will return the exchange that's
absolutely clear what I want is ideally
a decent night in this position against
this bishop on b1
he takes this free up that Bishop see
takes looks better from a structure
point of view so an interesting moment
you can also go Quincy three
intermediate move but that I've checking
on how is taking their okay okay taking
where the king is this with too weird I
guess so here he opens this so I'm going
here for 97 to c5 that is nice okay
queen here I guess f6 I will take and
I'm I have fun Queen deform if possible
I am somewhat ahead on the clock that's
good
my ideas I'm like 3d for checkin maybe
rupee eight trying to exploit this
activity so Queen you five here or it's
difficult to yeah I probably have to my
damn desk is still screeching I did
something against it and now it's back
okay what is the point Fraggles 95
okay I wonder if there's some kind of
trick that I have or just this move I
mean this is not bad let's do it it's
simple and not bad just blocking f6
now it looks good and now I just need to
somehow rookie 824 check will be three
there's this kind of ideas or this one
and actually threatening made and now
look h4 is not bad but I wonder about c5
if that is somehow a problem why not
really how okay I didn't see that I
simply forgot about this possibility
that i didn't see it was hanging it's a
shame really and now rooks III and the
night h5 or something are they if he
takes here give it a tag F sound that's
not good okay and just drop back now I
can move that night as f7 is projected
time morning yeah b7 is attacked I
cannot play walks III do this
can I trap it somehow it looks really
weird down don't know what this andrew
k2 it's not bad context it's constantly
praying some kind of tricks to the table
95 Queen f7 don't really know office is
working I don't know god damn check
check check check is it a draw and is a
draw draw chalford dried our fence oh ok
I offered I offered it but what can you
do I also only had one second left yeah
well it was of course I should just win
this here but I somehow lost track him
Jim engine wants to chat check and clean
95 that's typically cold-blooded I was
afraid of this but I can to take he I'm
with the temple on the roof and then
Queen f4 ok added that's indeed it's
quite moves the rook winner for is
pretty clear
yeah that's a pretty clear business this
is was a it was a good good possibility
but here I'm also just a lot better I
really didn't see that 83 was saying I
totally forgot about this unnai g4 was
winning instantly Wow yeah I just a
complete winner there was a bit
irritated at while I'm still I'm still
clearly better him down night 94 is good
and I can take with an idea I I thought
that it might be possible but I wasn't
totally sure about this I have to go to
hear you know and it looked kind of
crazy I didn't want to stumble into some
weird checkmate but there really is none
right yeah it was my suspicions but I
wasn't completely sure I'm like this I
don't hear there are tricks check I
don't know I was a tricky game thanks
for watching